it has come out that Patriots fans turn
to pornography immediately this is real
Patriots fans in mass turn to
pornography immediately after the
Superbowl immediately after they lost
they turn to pornography now ladies and
gentlemen as a Patriots fan I just like
to say that I for one waited for my
guests to leave
that's the standard move
I'm the wife [ __ ] scene yeah yeah the
Winter Olympics you getting excited
starts Thursday okay yeah I couldn't
tell if that was real excitement or not
I didn't I couldn't tell if they were
really excited or they just I mentioned
it they're like well I got it right
right either way it doesn't matter uh
this is the latest officials at the
Winter Olympics have stopped the Olympic
Village with over 100,000 condoms yeah
yeah in other words it sounds like Bob
Costas will be there
we've seen that guy he's a machine sorry
this incredible talk about the Winter
Olympics but after decades of bitter
bitter fighting North Korea and South
Korea will march together in the Winter
Olympics get this even more unbelievable
yesterday Melania Trump went to Ohio
with her husband
there's a thaw the mexican-american
judge that Donald Trump insulted may
hear a case about his border wall yeah
yeah it's the landmark case of Donald
Trump versus paybacks a [ __ ]
in San Diego this is a cool story in San
Diego a Girl Scout is in trouble for
selling cookies outside a legal weed
dispensary yeah
however the girl isn't worried because
she is now worth 200 million dollars
[Applause]
you